joining me now is Tennessee Congressman
Andy ogles who represents the Nashville
district where the Covenant School is
located Congressman that came after you
about the picture a holiday card which
was so ridiculous so predictable but
would you demand tonight that Merrick
Garland open a hate crimes investigation
into the shooting
yeah actually I've authored a letter uh
to the doj asking this that this be
classified as I hate crime and be
investigated as such look Federal code
18 USC 249 a1s you know if someone
willfully causes bodily harm because of
uh race color religion it's a hate crime
right and so we have uh the shooter this
domestic terrorist who wrote A Manifesto
uh targeting Christians children at a
Christian School this rise to the bar of
being considered a hate crime or at
least being investigated as such
well CBS has decided it's not worth
mentioning that the killer was
transgender according to the New York
Post CBS Executives Congressman said the
shooter's gender identity has not been
confirmed by CBS News we should avoid
any mention of it as it has no known
relevance to the crime
your reaction to that tonight
Congressman because I'm sure they'd do
that if they if the killer was a member
of the NRA or something
oh yeah I mean this clearly is just
pursuing a leftist agenda look you know
those folks that rushed and stormed the
Tennessee State Capitol by the way if
you were to use j6 as the model every
one of those people should be
incarcerated without due process
obviously as someone who believes in
Justice we wouldn't advocate for that
but the model is there and the
government's being weaponized against us
but but look you know this clearly is uh
someone was deeply troubled in the idea
that that guns are the problem here is
ridiculous this this individual had uh
you know mental illness uh in the in a
murderer and you know those people that
stormed the capital they held up the
number seven meaning that there were
seven victims no there were six victims
there was one murderer and that murderer
is a domestic terrorist well I have to
get your reaction to this uh statement
from Senator Elizabeth Warren watch
I just can't tell you how frustrating
this is our children die
because there are republicans in
Congress who continue to insist that we
can't put just basic safety measures
Congressman your response
well you know look the the crime
prevention Research Center conducted a
study in fact it was just updated in
2019 going back to 1950 and 94 of all
public mass shootings were occurred in
gun-free zones the answer isn't taking
away guns the answer is letting any
teacher who wants to get the proper
training and again it's permissive if
they want to do it we should give them
the opportunity to arm themselves and to
protect our children Congressman thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else